check check check check check
check check check check check check
check
are we live is it happening are we are
we on is anybody out there hello is
there anybody at all it's coming through
now calm it's like the day after whoo
that was good very good welcome to fat
man Beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
barnard oh six feet social distance this
is a responsible so social distancing
look I'm wearing gloves as well
rubber gloves you know what I've
discovered in the [ __ ] pandemic and
the quarantine and [ __ ] huh
like I like wearing gloves I was driving
and I was wearing my gloves and I was
like I felt like goes into 20s Auto
movies here to get away yeah like
[ __ ] driving gloves and [ __ ] like I'm
gonna start wearing gloves again not
this [ __ ] you know this is for the
pandemic but after the pandemic on get a
nice pair of like [ __ ] driving gloves
a bit of a hole in the tire I'm not
saying like I'm a militant vegan but it
seems kind of you know maybe if I could
repurpose the leather but what do they
call it if it's sustainable if I go to
the real real sounds like a [ __ ] but
I do I like wearing gloves you know what
I also have discovered during the
[ __ ] pandemic huh so we're all
washing our hands a lot a lot you tell
me if this happens to you as a man
hmm so I'll do something I go wash my
hands water very very hot yes as soon as
I get them washing my hands instantly I
have to take a piss because the hot-ass
water makes me have to pee is that the
same for you see a doctor when this is
all over oh my god dude I washed my
hands under the hottest ass water and
[ __ ] for two happy birthdays and then by
the time I'm done I'm like God and then
it's so hot that it [ __ ] heats my
body up it makes me have to pee then I
go [ __ ] pee then I have to come out
wash my [ __ ] hands again you're never
gonna be empty at this rate these
firstworldproblems out of line here we
are doing our show ladies and gentlemen
from the scum and villainy Cantina here
in Hollywood on hollywood boulevard but
it's empty as in per accordance with the
law and stuff like that out close to the
public
does broadcasters man JC has renamed it
for the evening the scum and villainy
quarantine ax nice sir did their
wordplay and we're here to chitchat and
go over the news as if nothing has
happened as if everything's normal
see we normally stand this far apart
from what we do know that you're here
everybody got JC in the booth adjacent
got Andrew back their switch cameras and
stuff like that if you're tuning in for
the first time for fat man beyond you
might be like why do they always stand
this far apart is it a race thing oh not
at all it's normally we're behind the
bar we're very [ __ ] cozy but we
didn't mention for the record you
brought it into race I'm sorry went
there but no we we would prefer of
course to be close to one another so we
could do gentle ribbing and things that
men do metaphorically you know but we
also bowed to social pressure in as much
as we were like I don't what if we stand
it too close than the Internet's like
you [ __ ] like we think we might take
a little heat for even doing this at all
I know I took some heat from my wife she
was like were you going yeah I was I
kind - did you really like can't you do
this over the internet like I would have
thought you'd be happy to see me [ __ ]
no she's like where you go I said go to
the cantina and she's like oh my god the
germs I don't know if you [ __ ] know
this or not the whole [ __ ] town to
shut down there ain't nobody there play
and she was like you have to wear
[ __ ] rubber gloves and [ __ ] and I was
like like our sex life and so here I am
wearing rubber gloves but I did fall in
love with the [ __ ] touch of a rubber
glove man I honestly like [ __ ] like
remember all the sitcoms we grew up
watching the black and white ones that
were in syndication yeah we're moms
always do the housework and [ __ ] they
put on rubber gloves dude I could have
been a 50s house mom and I so much I
like these rubber gloves yeah you're
like a 50s house mom meets like crazy
CIA proctological interrogated I saw I
was driving here of course I had my
hands at 10:00 and 2:00 as you should
what drives tend to do kids now this is
like ebbs rules pocket but I saw I was
at a light and I saw like I was jockey
next to a police officer two cops in a
car and I'm holding the wheel with my
rubber gloves on they look at me for one
second they look and then they look away
any other time in this world if they saw
a random guy with gloves rubber gloves
on driving around they'd be like pull
over or they follow me or something but
now they're like pandemic ion cabin and
they didn't even blink he said doctor
giggles I think that's that Wrath of
Khan diseases come back in time from 80s
Cable we've had nothing else to do what
have you been doing during the
quarantine a mark I have I have been not
writing as much as I should
yeah it's shocking how much I thought
I'd be writing a lot more I'm dude I am
writing much more on one project I've
been closing up Masters of the Universe
so tying up all the scripts and whatnot
when you're showrunner this is why I
like for years I was always like man be
great to run a [ __ ] show now I'm like
no it ain't because at a certain point
like all the you do all the writing when
at a certain point when everybody's
drafts they're a lot of drafts are done
any changes that like Mattel and Netflix
wants done they're like alright well you
could do these and I'm like oh can I and
it's literally work and it becomes like
not work like this [ __ ] nine-to-five
but you know suddenly I'm like oh I
wanted to be writing clerks Mallrats
that being said when I dove back into
the scripts and stuff like I could drown
in Eternia it we got some good [ __ ]
scripts on that show man this [ __ ]
masters universe show it's like a ways
away and whatnot like a year away but it
is I'm so proud of it it's it's crazy
[ __ ] good particularly based on the
IP like based on the toys and stuff it's
it turned into something nice you ever
get to the point when
and I haven't quite gotten there yet
because I haven't had to run my own show
but I've gotten series of notes from
various people and haven't you ever like
would you just stop reading it like if
you keep reading it you're gonna keep
finding stuff I have absolutely had that
not in this project but in other
projects and also in like mic test
screenings the camera we test green
jersey girl for a year man we did like
12 test screenings in different parts of
the country
there's always irritating to me because
you test screen it to an audience and
that audience gives you a bunch of notes
where they're like you know change this
change this fix that if you did that
movie be great like alright and then you
go fix that [ __ ] then you have another
test screening but it's not with that
same audience which would make a lot of
sense if it was just like hey kids
remember this movie we watched last week
I made the changes you asked for here
you are instead you're showing it to a
whole new audience and they have a whole
new set of [ __ ] notes man so the
whole time is always like can we like
just show it to one audience over and
over and then their logic was they'll
get sick of it and I'm like I'm [ __ ]
sick of it man like when is it done I'm
sure that movie wasn't done for a while
but what is so you haven't been writing
as much as you thought yeah I mean I've
been working on on the day job which I
won't even mention but you all know what
it is really so that the beginning of
that job is gonna be done from home yeah
I spent a week in the room and then it
was hey everybody we're spending the
rest of our lives at home by the feel of
it so now it's a lot of like zoom
meetings where it's the Hollywood
Squares sofa the final frontier this is
the voyage of the starship or Nardin
yeah I will sit here I mean is it this
is what I think is gonna happen because
I was watching you know I'm fascinated
by I love Late Night with Seth Meyers
but all the late night shows you know
they're the [ __ ] stream in a Jif
version of we're home it's some version
of there's some version of their show
literally at home and stuff and you know
I looked I watched like a closer look
that things he does every
a you know and they get big numbers on
YouTube they'll rack up millions of hits
deep dives into the issues of the day
he did one from his house a day ago two
days ago from it's like [ __ ] hallway
which like it looked like a you know a
90s serial killers one angle with a VHS
camera and it's got more hits then a
closer look normally has on YouTube any
not really the metric maybe but it's a
decent metric you know if you look along
the time line they're very popular but
the one at home doubly popular now if
I'm running a network and we all go back
to work months from now maybe years from
now one of the first things I'd say is
like I'm cutting your budget like you
don't have to spend all this money to
browse still literally watch you in your
[ __ ] hallway like are you crazy
spending all this [ __ ] do you think it's
gonna change the way writers rooms work
you know I I I don't think so at least I
don't think I don't think it's never
going to be a bunch of people in a room
together talking right I don't think
that that experience is just like the
technology's not quite there yet
something good comes from everybody
being in the same room it really does
and lunch like they you know writers
really really really love lunch and at
this point nobody's bringing me lunch
with me it's well yeah but that end in
[ __ ] post mates I'd imagine yeah but
even still like I said I gonna walk out
I got it I gotta choose things writers
are the laziest people in the world if
you let them get that way who makes the
orders then for lunch there's a writers
PA who's like I've always dreamed of
being a writer get me a sandwich that's
you literally if that was the route I
would have had to have taken I never
the businessman thank you God for indie
film because the notion of like I just
want to put words together and like
before you do that I put lunch together
a lot of sandwiches make me a sandwich
I'm hungry cuz I'm a writer
writers black there's mustard on this no
I hate mustard
you got to go back and fix it oh my god
the worst but I think that the things
will happen like I was talking to one of
my managers today and they're like we're
getting more work done now than we've
ever gotten done before because nobody
has any excuses we all know where you
are there's no like I'm on the golf
course or I'm out of lunch or I'm gonna
whatever's like no you're at your
[ __ ] desk yeah
answer the call or if you're not
answering it now I know that the reasons
behind it like the excuses have gone
away it's true but I think that that
what this will allow is for writers to
be on location and on set and still be
able to be part of the room experience
which is hey Jim is gonna pipe in from
[ __ ] Vancouver and we're gonna talk
about this stuff like sicknesses become
different like you know if you've got a
bit treat or something or surgery
whatever like now you could still be
part of it because we've shown you can
do it mmm I think it's you know I think
all of this is going to change the world
in smaller ways than we think they are
I I do you know a lot of people like
wearing things are gonna go back to
normal do you think things are ever
gonna go back to the normal we knew I
don't think it's always gonna be like
this where it's like we're in lockdown
and [ __ ] but I think a lot of things are
about to change man I think it's funny I
was talking about this with a friend and
nobody could have foreseen that the most
lasting effect on the personal lives of
Americans of 9/11 is taking these shoes
off when you fly that is like on the on
the grand scale that's the effect that
we have he was a massive you know
worldwide thing definitely a countrywide
thing it just it changed the face of
America for like five years and then
those things began to slip away it's
like sure there's still roadblocks in
front of buildings and they're still
like armed guards in public places that
didn't used to be but on a day to day
basis in your daily life that's the
thing that that maintains and you could
not have predicted that you couldn't
have God in your life [ __ ] Wayback
Machine and be like alright Kreskin
what's it gonna be like in 30 years
one day I'm have to slip out of my
loafers won't go on st. Louis yeah I
gotta put my laptop in a bag so yeah I
don't the world is going to change but
it's it's I don't think it's gonna
change in some giant dramatic way but
it's gonna be some small way that you
couldn't have seen like oh really it's
good that's that a lot of people have
been asking me and I do I don't know I
guess three is not a lot but three
different outlets have asked me to
comment on the movie business as if like
[ __ ] I know anything but like you
know what's gonna is everything ever
gonna be the same again and blah blah
blah I'm like I didn't even get back to
anybody cuz I'm like I've no take on
this whatsoever it already changed for
me a while ago so I don't know you know
I think we've seen movie theaters have
asked the government for a [ __ ] what
do they call that bailout bailout part
of the stimulus or whatnot you know I
don't think movie theaters are ever
gonna go away I think you know but well
we've now seen some movies coming out
digitally case in point I watched birds
of prey on Tuesday at home as well see
any visible man's already playing on the
big the big yeah the hunt is a good real
big test and as is Ben's movie the way
way back that was just in a theater and
stuff the week before and you know this
has been the thing that ex exhibitors
have been fighting for years now like
the idea of the theatrical window
getting smaller and smaller and now this
pandemic has kind of given you know
Studios an excuse to be like well let's
see what happens if we charge twenty
bucks would you be willing to rent the
hunt that's what I paid for it yeah and
you know I watched it with my wife I was
I was not sitting there like oh man like
it was way cheaper than going out to the
movie theater so they'll probably and
you know a lot of people have figured
that out long ahead of the pandemic but
you might see some of that erosion or
you might see the other thing which is
like we've all been indoors for so long
by the time they're like you're free to
go out like every movie theater will be
packed you know people just try to get
back to normalcy as much as
I don't know I have no window into the
future the one thing I'm surprised
hasn't happened or at least hasn't
happened on the scale that I thought it
might maybe it's just because they're
all gone
cannibalism coming I've been waiting for
it
I got my good teeth drive-in movies yeah
you know like and and did there was some
I remember news article a couple years
ago like the last American drive-in
closed and you know Rahway New Jersey
where there was but that is perfect
social distancing fee and exhibition you
drive up in the car keep the windows
closed you bring your own snacks you
tune in your radio this is we go like
the governor announced the closure like
member they did all the closings then
this week they announced additional
closings on that list drive-in movie
theaters well number one I'm like
multiple plural there was move there's
there's a bunch in this state but number
two yeah because instantly like Seth
Siegel my agent at William Morris was
like you like you like drive-ins what
about a drive-in tour like you can take
the movie out and like do your Q&A and
everybody's in their car same thing
that'd be fun man that'd be great and
stuff so suddenly this week on Monday or
Tuesday the governor was like no driving
driving movie theaters are close to I
guess at the end of the day you have to
pass off money I don't know why they did
it everyone's in their own cars instead
but they just want us to stay home don't
even leave yeah which obviously we're
abiding by this is I mean I go hiking
they closed Runyon Canyon and I felt for
you when I saw that it's all right I
live on a hill so I just go back to hike
and that but it's like a you know it's
like the bunny slope compared to Runyon
Canyon so I just got to do it twice but
that yeah so I haven't been out of the
house and so this this is us out and
it's one two three four of us in a very
large space with lots of space yes we're
a parallelogram between us I'm wearing
gloves I don't know his [ __ ] excuses
he thinks it's gonna live forever
it's the melanin keeping me strong
though read online perhaps that I was
more susceptible as a white man but I
think that's just it's probably bull
hockey yeah yeah I think you know movies
will probably go back to some version of
the way was which was already favoring
giant blockbusters in theaters yeah and
Indies going to some version of Netflix
or Apple TV or a streamer first and then
some kind of physical media may be
getting a cursory theatrical release
just cuz mm-hmm I think that might
broaden even further
you know just cuz they've seen now that
people if their home will actually pay
money for the for a movie they haven't
seen before
I would [ __ ] man I honestly I would have
paid 100 but nobody wants to hear this
but I would have paid 100 bucks to like
watch the hunt at home do not because of
my kids that [ __ ] good although it
was enjoyable it was just like oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna save me a lot of time yeah I
mean there already is in LA especially
in Beverly Hills I think they call like
that ballet our circuit wishes or Prima
I think might have been the the
trademark name but it was a very very
exclusive high-end streaming service for
theatrical releases that if you spend
like 20 grand a year for membership to
this thing you got to watch movies day
and date at home I I'm gonna reveal
something here maybe far to telling
about me I don't spend a lot of money on
things that might might be an
extravagance that I'd be like do tell go
on like I know some people like I'm in a
netjet so I like to [ __ ] have a piece
of a jet I got two homes
I got [ __ ] man I got a nice house I'm
gonna be wrong but like I don't over by
that holy [ __ ] are you kid this is the
thing you gotta live in bel-air though I
don't think so I think but it's like
that's where it started is what rich
people do like Seth MacFarlane like
people like [ __ ] have movie theaters
in their house they always had that part
of that private circuit where they could
get a brand new print on day of release
but nobody makes prints anymore so I
guess this is this is the new version of
that that's the [ __ ] you know that's
why we gathered here today
to find this out let's go eat the rich
kids they're getting all the good movies
at home woman who can't get up the
really rigidity in their like summer
homes in Belize ah those elites taking
our [ __ ] motion picture they get to
see trolls the world tour before we do
good for them
Wow let's [ __ ] who knew next time
somebody like ask me well wife's like
what do you want for your birthday
happen to be like funny you should ask
there's a very overpriced system by
which we could watch movies at home we
could spend $15 a ticket we're 20 grand
a year you tell me gifts a gift I give
something you would never buy for
yourself alright so here we are and you
know as the as a guy who wakes up every
morning and reads Google News lately all
the news mark has been of course yeah
about this pesky pathogen yeah but there
must be entertainment news there's
there's a little bit you dig summer I
dug some up I unearth some home art it
it took some doing you know and there's
there's and there's not too much because
we could have made a giant [ __ ] list
about the movies that are canceled the
movies that are pushed the events that
are canceled so haunting driving around
town I'm sure it's this way like any
place that's got billboards but driving
around town and seeing like billboards
for movies that aren't haven't come out
and aren't coming out yeah like it's
like wait February that should be out
right now New Mutants huh you mean while
somebody's like that's not haunting bro
what's haunting is like people dying
from this thing which absolutely does
awning and we absolutely know that but
we're here to talk about the distraction
look over here kids see the clown with
the rubber gloves yes pay no attention
to his hatchet what news what news
whither the news mark what news what
what Yonder news break yes well there
was there's a news item today
broke okay patty Jenkins was interviewed
hey Jenkins patty Jenkins director of
wonder woman 84 which is now going to
open in August wonderful lady they've
moved Wonder Woman to August to August
but you know they had this maybe she can
beat up this [ __ ] virus you know I
bet you're famous Gary she bet you she
could [ __ ] block it somebody like
coming out of a germ she's like ping
ping ping ping ping ping ping do it all
Zack Snyder fast between ping ping and
then some guy pulls out a gun and
threatens a child that's Justice League
yeah I just watched it again in
quarantine I've been rewatching all the
DC Universe movies yeah the DC EU if you
will yeah you know honestly like any
time I come up against it you know one
where I'm like well this is totally
different than I would imagine whatever
I always think about how when we read
comics the same person didn't know he's
right Batman
sometimes someone would write Batman in
a way where you're like well let's new
you know so sometimes it's like that I'm
like oh that's that's new so I've been
while I've been rewatching those so yeah
Vanity Fair had what I have to imagine
was supposed to be a cover story pegged
to the release of Wonder Woman and a
big-ass interview patty Jenkins right in
which she talks about she was initially
supposed to be the director of Thor the
dark world yeah that's right man um she
was she was it was a big announcement
and she was very excited about it
because it's a big [ __ ] deal at that
point like a woman hadn't directed a
superhero movie let alone a Marvel movie
let alone one of their sort of giant
franchise patty it comes from indie
world she directed monster yes that had
been the movie before
Wonder Woman mm-hmm and she eventually
walked away from it and so she for the
first time I think on the record just
kind of went straight at it to explain
why she did and her quote was I did not
believe that I could make a good movie
out of the script that they were
planning on doing and I think it would
have been a huge deal that would have
looked like it was my fault it would
have looked like oh my god this woman
directed it and she missed all these
things there was one time in my career
where I really felt like do this with
any other director and it's not gonna be
a big deal and maybe they'll understand
it and loved it more than I do
you can't do movies you don't believe in
the only reason to do it would be to
prove to people that I could
but I wouldn't have proved anything if I
didn't succeed I don't think I would
have gotten another chance and so I'm
super grateful Wow
that's perspective she's cool lady man I
talked to it Sundance like last year the
year before
she's the goods yeah like I get that I
mean it's never happened to me because
nobody who's ever like here do something
important but I can see like [ __ ] if
you were standing on the threshold and
you're like this ain't gonna happen and
I'm gonna get blamed
like you know negatives you're the one
like if you're the it's like I'm gonna
be there [ __ ] if Jackie Robinson is
shitty at baseball hmm then does
baseball change sports thing baseball
thing yeah what is what do you mean mark
babe babe what if you are the first to
the door yes the pressure on you to
succeed being the first of the door is
higher than it is if you were just a
5800 through the door there's an analogy
I understand having been through a door
to in my life you know like it would
have been if she takes that movie and it
turns out shitty they would have said
turns out women can't direct giant
action movies but we took our shot
didn't work out let's go find another
dude and as we saw later on she sure
does know how to make them giant action
movies she really does we should be
getting another Wonder Woman trailer
shouldn't we now that they've moved the
movie in August I would think I would
think I demand it bring it yes what is
well we I did patty J I was gonna say we
love Paige Angus I can't speak for Marc
but I like her quite a bit I dig her
she's [ __ ] the goods man did it she
didn't say anything about didn't one
like Jane like didn't wasn't wasn't she
wanted to me like this kind of Romeo and
Juliet who did it aroma it's patty like
she wanted her Thor to to be way more of
a romance between those two characters
but didn't like what natalie portman get
mad too I think she got mad when patty
walked away with it but did she stay in
the movie yeah she's in it but she was
and then she was like I never doing this
[ __ ] again and walked yeah and I think
she did because of they had fired patty
Jenkins if I remember correctly yeah I
think his patty was her pick like that
was that was sort of you
I'll screw down Natalie Portman's she's
gonna be in Thor for the new Thor yeah
love and thunder no ask Thor
well she got over that thank God oh god
movies gonna be cool I mean I think it
was also I have to think that the
experience of making the dark world for
her was not overly rosy and I'm sure
sitting on the sidelines and watching
like yeah Marvel become Marvel was like
uh okay come back and also like tyke is
a fantastic director and you look at
what he did with that movie and
everybody wants to because so clever and
imaginative yeah adorable so so yeah
that that was the thing that came out
and what a woman is getting pushed this
is August August I don't know when
exactly in August but WW 84 looks good I
can't wait looks great
honestly the trailer looks really cool I
want more though we know we all want to
see I mean maybe I'm like we all want to
show B yeah I try not to be that guy
because there's another guy who's always
in the news who says everybody says no
no if anybody says but I personally am
waiting to see cheetah in a big bad way
yeah I mean I think if you're interested
in this movie then you're interested in
seeing that feels like it's a clean you
think they're gonna hold on to the flick
or we're gonna get a taste to that in
the next trailer what would you do
you're marking in the movie do you give
him a taste of cheetah if we were
renaming the episode that's what I'd
call this one it tastes - cheetah the
taste of cheetah what would you would
you would you give him a taste of
cheetah would you make him wait and go
the movie theater I I think I'd make him
wait I think I'd make him wait because I
what a little [ __ ] you are what I am
but imagine imagine how much more
excited you would have been at thor
ragnarok if you didn't know the hulk was
in it i mean but it would have been
stupid man to not market the movie going
like walks in this shed yeah but like
there's a way you could have done it
they just chose not to when I get it
like it's you're trying to sell you put
your big [ __ ] dick on the table and
say please come and see it but I think
more marketing 101 kids if you're ever
wondering how something installed they
is rewind listen this you put your big
old dick on the table as Mike says I'm
gonna chop it up and sell it coming soon
coming it's worked for porn for a long
no doubt man but I also think like at
that point Marvel is somewhat
impenetrable and that we were gonna go
see it anyway and so did you need
wouldn't that have been great in that
sequence and the contest of Champions
when he revealed that his opponent is
actually yes but I
yes you're absolutely right but I would
argue Thor was kind of on the ropes at
that point too because dark world did it
no favors and stuff so like you know
they wanted to come back with like a
let's make a Thor that people want to
see and they did [ __ ] we all wanted
to see in a big bad way so I could you
know in order to do that though like
let's let everybody know the [ __ ] we
got something cool here you got to put
the Hulk in the trailers man yeah so
back to my point back to your panocha
you're in charge of marketing at Warner
Brothers I don't think so that's just me
thank God he's just a writer not the CEO
of marketing
what's next mark well we it's news that
has happened since we last recorded but
I think that most of the world knows by
this point without the mandalorian has
revealed some casting information all
right pause yes when last we gathered I
had not seen the mandalorian that's
right I have since seen the mandalorian
you are now on board with the mando oh
it's not like I wasn't on board before I
was just busy with Jay and Silent Bob
reboot wrote short tour but finally in
the middle of the quarantine I was like
you know what [ __ ] role every upside
a Sunday down or weekday doors who knows
what the days are anymore but I was like
I'm gonna give this role man sat down
popped on the TV and [ __ ] I was not
prepared and believe me I'd been hiked
by you by the whole [ __ ] world like
there were no surprises on new baby Yoda
I knew [ __ ] IG 11 I knew I knew dark
sabers and [ __ ] didn't [ __ ] matter
it is so masterfully [ __ ] made it is
the show of my childhood dreams and I
want to ask you this yeah does it feel
like a 1970 show every episode
particularly when you get into the end
credits with the [ __ ] drawings of
what happened that oh my god it makes me
so happy it's like a [ __ ] time
machine it makes me brings me right back
like honestly the whole first half of
the watch I was like this reminds me of
the Planet of the Apes TV show or not
the plan of the Apes TV show per se
because this shows way [ __ ] better but
how I felt as a kid when I was like
we're watching Planet of the Apes on
[ __ ] TV you know long before there
was cable and streaming and all that
[ __ ]
like it's going and these guys knew
Cornelius and like it was not same thing
as I watched this I'm like watching
[ __ ] Star Wars man on TV it's a
goddamn show and he looks like the upper
bound on her and he looks like the other
bounty hunter and this [ __ ] are not
not like all of it it's so beautifully
like it's not even a remix man it's just
it literally plays in the universe in
such a wonderful way like hats off to
those cats and and I've wrote about it
online and people were like man you
should direct an episode [ __ ] no I would
ruin it but I'll tell you right now I
would love to be in that [ __ ] show in
a heartbeat I'd be in that show are you
kidding me you never heard me ever say
in this lifetime I always wanted to make
a Star Wars anything but being a Star
Wars [ __ ] thing [ __ ] yeah man because
a lot of people watch that yeah and
you're all about this and oh my god it'd
be like so fun they look like they're
having a good time like bill birnes in
an episode and what was her name you
know Amy Sedaris like it's fun man and J
is Sudeikis did a day and Adam pally
like it's it's been real fun to watch
what's his name
you know mr. krabs tall dude buckaroo
banzai you know Lex Luthor in the
Justice League cartoon oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
I smoked it left gal no boys
[ __ ] you know guy man and he's
Mandalorian he played the big guy with
the horns Clancy Brown thank you I
smoked [ __ ] Clancy Brown away
Clancy [ __ ] Brown he's great isn't it
man took a long way to get to that name
and then eventually just close with he's
but he's great in it he's [ __ ]
wonderful that he looks like the dude in
the cantina bar from Star Wars
everything like is an echo not
everything because it's like a very
original story while being a very old
story at the same time you know it's
[ __ ] lone wolf and cub to a large
degree but man just [ __ ] wonderful
like just bliss and I saw I talked about
it when I went to the Scott Roger
Skywalker premiere I saw Favreau and
stuff and I hadn't seen the show and he
was like oh my god you're everywhere I
see you everywhere as it I haven't seen
your show yeah I remember everyone says
is great and stuff I was like in that
baby Otis [ __ ] everywhere man did you
come up with that and he goes yes I
wrote the whole show I think you did he
was like yes I never really thought
about provider you know he's director
and an actor and stuff but I was like
man like this yes it capture everyone's
imagination then I saw the [ __ ] show
nothing but respect not real respect to
that guy zip me out look I loved him and
then again this ain't me blowing anybody
try to get a job I don't want a [ __ ]
that [ __ ] looks complicated although I
will be in it but [ __ ] just like Iron
Man which is a movie i rewatch at least
once a month no [ __ ] he's a master
storyteller man like [ __ ] it is it's
so [ __ ] beautiful like that show and
you know maybe I'm like he's a master
storyteller but I've never seen Cowboys
and Aliens of you yeah it's that count I
mean it's not a masterful work maybe
it's maybe he's like a master
storyteller with [ __ ] I like what I mean
like because he took Marvel and [ __ ]
made it you know made it wonderful and
we kept apart and now he's taking Star
Wars with Dave Filoni and they're making
it like wonderful man so I trust that
dude with all the big heavy IP they
should let Favreau touch everything I
mean that sounds terrible yeah you got
to wear gloves Pat's
but they should like oh it's [ __ ]
great sand
now having said all that about season
one of the Mandalorian [ __ ] Giancarlo
Esposito dude buggin out this is broke
he got out of the [ __ ] time you got
time for your sad we're gonna board
gotcha fat bust ass you're gonna boycott
me how would you boycott that was a
little scene from do the right thing and
[ __ ] get out of typewriter whip out
the dark saber yeah and I love him I
know people know him from like [ __ ]
Gus fring Breaking Bad but I go deep
cuts man like like all the early Spike
Lee stuff I was always a big fan of so
when I saw him come out of the dark say
Rosic holy [ __ ] what a great choice just
great choices across the board leading
right into they made another great
choice they did rosario dawson oh is and
to say like is joining the cast is weird
because they've already finished
shooting she's in and they did it they
kept me why it's all done production is
over on season 2 they're just now
meeting out how that's not even them
going like that's so that's enough for
season three she's in season two yeah
maybe she pops up at the end of season
two and it's all cuz they kept it that
quiet she could be in more than one up
you think she's a they can you finish
the sentence I'm so excited I mean they
they they seem to be doing the job of
keeping [ __ ] quiet that almost nobody
else can do because they shoot inside a
[ __ ] barn right and there's no
location shooting there's no long
telephoto lenses like [ __ ] show
up to work they do their thing and they
leave and so yeah I don't think they've
even their writing season three now but
they've they're just say hey guess who's
in season two you want to know [ __ ]
Rose I didn't know was just playing
ahsoka tano oh this is such great news
this is something we talked about on
this show many times not even like a new
notion to us man I've been wanting this
for a while with no disrespect to who's
what's the little girl that played her
in the car Ashley Ashley who do who
created my her universe part of the you
know her universe her universe that you
said in my universe it's a Maya then are
correct
but no disrespect her she's wonderful ah
but Rosario has wanted to do this like
every time somebody like live action
ahsoka she's always like oh my god
that's my dream Roland [ __ ] she loves
all this like genre stuff so it's cool
casting very very cool casting yeah like
in a world of bad news that was [ __ ]
great news man
right and it's it doesn't seem as if
it's not a series regular role according
to Deadline it seems as if it's either a
one or two Episode thing or maybe two
extended cameo it'll be the first
live-action Asoka other than Rises
Skywalker we heard her voice it was so
good and you know when all the Jedi's
was were in Rey which sounds way [ __ ]
dirtier than was intended so we heard
her voice in live-action but we've never
seen a live-action representation
correct this will be the first this will
be the first this is genius this is so
[ __ ] smart who created it so who was
the Dave Filoni I'm not sure who the
writer on the episode was but it was on
Clone Wars so yeah my god he gets to
take some of that credit I want these
kids to keep make 10 years 10 years of
this [ __ ] show this is like it's
reinvigorated me as a fan like it dialed
my clock back it took me back to before
I used to do things and before you know
pop culture was a [ __ ] was currency
and everybody was in on it [ __ ] it took
me back to the 70s to a pure [ __ ]
time man and I was like that's if you
can do that with a [ __ ] television
show or anything master you're a
masterful artist and much like the 70s
it's it feels a little bit I'm not going
to say loveboat cuz Love Boat is a
little pejorative but the guest star is
some do some exciting and new come we're
expecting you
and I want a Cosmo we can't mark went
for the right for what another one we
can't because of the virus in trip but
number two you went for the extended cap
when they didn't have enough guest stars
they did the long version of the theme
song when they had too many guest stars
it was like right after that then they
were like laughs oh they were right into
the course but when they were like they
only had three people and it was mostly
a boat show that night you know mostly
about Isaac or Julie we've got 45
seconds long one Lou Rawls I say another
[ __ ] 70s keV love that joke okay like
The Love Boat it seems that they have
this kind of cavalcade of guest stars
coming in like first season you got
Bilborough you got Amy Sedaris you had
and wonderful Mike unobvious choices yes
great actors and actresses but like not
like oh the usual social you know like
Werner Herzog's and everything these
[ __ ] amazing was he
what a great casting call that was he
was awesome and of course [ __ ] baby
Yoda like literally lives up to all the
hype I love that baby Yoda is in great
part Werner Herzog's fault yeah he was
the one that was like he's a puppet
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] and wit as that doll
there's no reason it needs will be CG
there's a [ __ ] puppet I love it so
much man I when is that coming back they
say sooner than later it's it's
currently well the problem that people
are having is post-production is proving
difficult because even though it's
usually like an editor in a room but it
becomes more difficult when you've got
scoring and getting orchestra together
to record sound to do final mix downs of
all that stuff it's you know that is
putting a big sort of crimp in the very
tail end of the production industry
Carolyn oh mine who was the writer and
producer of the episode of The Simpsons
that I was on Sunday as myself drawn as
myself she mentioned in her tweet the
this is the first time she ever remotely
mixed an episode of The Simpsons and she
can't be in the same room and stuff so
she was at home and
watching as they mixed it and stuff a
lot of remote work I guess gonna be
happening yeah but like there's there's
just some elements of it specific and
alive score it's hard to do yeah oh yeah
I mean on Seth Meyers like they had and
one of the openings they had the five
members of his band all at home and they
were like zoomed in playing the opening
theme remotely it's kind of sweet yeah
there's a lot of that did you see that
one [ __ ] zoom video like poor
Jennifer you know so there's like
everyone's having like a zoom conference
there's like eight people in the
conference and one ladies talk and then
one lady gets up she's walkin around her
house with her laptop you know as you're
want to do or whatever then she puts the
laptop down in her bathroom and sits
down and goes to take a pee and everyone
and you're just seeing it everybody on
the [ __ ] group chat is like oh
they're all like laughing and smiling
and [ __ ] and and then [ __ ] suddenly
she realizes what maybe she looked down
and saw holy [ __ ] - view of her on the
toilet and she quick like [ __ ] turns
it around and stuff and then one guy
goes I didn't see anything and somebody
goes poor Jennifer yeah man it was
pretty is erroring and stuff but a good
reminder in the age of zoom don't take
it to the toilet I did that it with a
mix because I didn't know I had
headphones in and we were recording Tony
the wait was he announced yes he was
Tony the Tiger yeah she say Tony it's a
cast member who was announced no I think
he was dude I don't know I won't be the
one getting in trouble yeah all right so
I was recording someone remotely and I
was in New York and this person was
recording here in in Los Angeles and
particularly in Burbank instead and so I
had in my earbuds and whatever they're
called air pods and I didn't know like
whenever I put those in I would talk
into my phone like this so if I was
using those I'd be like cuz I thought
this is the receiver and these are just
the ear things things to hear I didn't
realize there are [ __ ] microphones in
the air pods so when you're on the phone
that's what they're hearing
so I left my bass in one room and chicks
we were waiting for somebody to get to
the microphone and I went to the
bathroom and like took a huge piss
probably a little fart out and spoke you
know went back thought like I got away
with that one day somebody was like you
know the microphones in the earpiece cuz
they saw me holding the phone up like
this like why doing that I was like
because you got to talking to the phone
I'm like no it's the microphones right
there it's like you there's no way it's
too far away from your mouth they're
like science bro and I was like what and
then I started thinking oh my god how
many times I warned that [ __ ] into the
bathroom always remember leave your [ __ ]
out it's supposed to be out in October
mandalorian season 2 yeah but they have
also since added Michael Biehn has
joined the cab get out of here yes sir
six Kyle Reese himself Kyle Reese man
like a [ __ ]
also Johnny Ringo yes Donna Ringo is an
educated man
now I hate him even more I got to piss
now I really hate the one for the both
these prime oh my god that's a good
movie I want to watch that now I love
that we're just doing [ __ ] Val Kilmer
chords mention Johnny Ringo we're just
doing [ __ ] Graham of the 10 caffeine
share draw all right you are my friend
oh my god what a beautiful movie that is
memory sees his feet at the end and he's
just like huh Val Kilmer men what man if
you love me all right what else we got
let's see I'm gonna save that story for
a little later
oh really yeah just because it gets a
little serious instead I'm gonna do a
story that has two of at least two of
your favorite things
New Jersey no and jaws Oh Bruce the
musical is set to hit stages in New
Jersey in 2021 a musical version based
on screenwriter Carl Gottlieb's 1975
memoir the jaws log
Bruce will be directed and written by
people who do things in Jersey
the papermill Playhouse oh my god there
dude the papermill Playhouse Playhouse I
know that place yeah so wait and it's
based on car call got leaves book the
jaws Lodge so it's a musical about the
making of Josie's about the making of
Jaws they sold me a ticket man when is
it begin I mean I know we're not allowed
to be in public anymore but when does it
begin
let's see well you got a year Bruce will
be in co-production with Seattle rep and
is set for June 9th in July 4th 2012 Oh
give me a time to save up money to fly
back to New Jersey and see it at the
papermill Playhouse something tells you
me that they would give you a ticket I
want to support that I don't want
anything for free I want to monetarily
support that kind of [ __ ] you want to
give me some tickets and some [ __ ] I
have no interest in fine but I will
[ __ ] financially support that that's
a good idea
it feels like July 4th is the day to go
see it really is I mean I guess that's
you get around working with the
universal by doing the jaws logbook yeah
like it's it no longer becomes a
copyright infringement I mean you're
right those are two of my favorite
things see if it only had weed all
together yeah [ __ ] got jaws in my
chocolate you got chocolate in my jaws
yeah that's funny there's there's also I
can't me what network is doing it but
they're making a making of Goonies TV
show it's like a dramatic version of
like behind the scenes and how it was
making Goonies you serious yeah that
sounds like an HBO max kind of show it
isn't really I want to say it's NBC but
one of the real Goonies of the real like
they're not like a goonie ish thing
no like they're doing with Amblin so
that like it's actual [ __ ] Goonies
Sara Watson who was a co-executive
producer in Parenthood and Friday Night
Lights created the bold type has been
like working with Spielberg and making a
[ __ ] show about the making of Goonies
why spielberg lets dick Donner thing but
it's a NAMBLA production yeah yeah but
you know not for nothing that's a dick
Donner [ __ ] that movie is more dick
Donner than [ __ ] dick Donner himself
you can tell a dick Donner movie
they're all [ __ ] the dickish and
Donna Schmidt
they're wonderful so like you know and I
understand Stevens
was a bump I ain't trying to take
anything away but sounds like if you're
in develop it with anybody
well wonder he's the one that's been out
there for years like every time the kids
get together and [ __ ] and he's like we
want to make another movie but they
never did it again yeah I mean one of
those two gentlemen has like an active
production company that makes things but
and that would be Steven Spielberg true
oh yeah all right it's live and they're
still in oh god anything can happen
ladies gentlemen and a tow truck has
come to take us away as the boys rush
away to get our cars out of the alley in
order to do the show here we park in the
back alley yeah and wasn't supposed to
be anybody who needed anything in the
bag early know if you heard just heard
that went well that was a neighbor who
was like I'm a [ __ ] Tony's piece of
[ __ ]
so we're on our own one camera oh I
don't know what to do now be honest with
that and know they're swishing all right
so John's the musical Goonies the
untitled Goonies show and potentially
coming to the next TV season nobody
knows what's happening with the next TV
season mark yeah I make a little
confession please do I am working with a
streamer as the kids call him the NASD
on a project of sorts and hopefully I'll
have news to share with other people
soon but I'll tell you this much today I
had to write a cover letter not had to
wanted to to a bonafide legend slash
movie star that we sent our script to
ooh how slobbery was this letter it was
it was it was it was respectfully like
it wasn't that slobbery it wasn't like
just tasteful where it's like oh sick a
fan but he definitely communicated that
I was deep cuts fan and had been for a
long long [ __ ] time and we share up
something like
culturally so to speak that I was able
to reference and stuff so if this person
goes for this thing
holy the [ __ ] it would it would be a I
mean it would be wonderful and fun for
me but it would actually make a [ __ ]
terrific show I'll let you know
I'm the hope trusts I've been vague
enough you know I think I know who it is
but looking firm after the break who is
it who is it great there's nobody you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna write this
down
and then I'm gonna see if you guessed it
right okay here we go
shouldn't I have written it down that's
why even though I've got the rubber
gloves I should never plan the murder
all right you write it down write it
down and then we'll see how close you
get okay new note JC's gone this place
is ours man now this is cool
mark and Kev's cantina scum and villainy
we can put mark in tape over scum and
Kevin over villainy yes you got it you
got it my friend you got it so you
understand what the thing we share pop
culturally I believe I do yes
so it was hopefully it's the beginning
of a beautiful friendship but it's a
long shot I'll tell you that right yeah
I I had to write one of those notes as
well and it didn't go anywhere so I can
say who I wrote it - because I saw it's
not like actively happening do it but I
had to write one didn't have to I got to
write one for Idris Elba the [ __ ] yeah
to be part of a project that you gave
him the coronavirus I really yeah I
totally sent him your letter with all
your germs on it with my uncle of it
ends
how'd it go boys okay I got a ride home
but yeah and I remembered like because
my manager is like hey yeah I think it
could use a personal touch if you want
to write a letter to go along with the
script as we send it over and so I wrote
a letter I sent there are we sick yeah
you know it could use a little bit more
Mike it's not a sloppy enough blow jobs
icky I needs to be a sloppier [ __ ]
okay
more tongue more spit spit on it more
note about it guys again that 20% did it
it didn't go anywhere like I think but
you did send a letter the letter went
and he received it or at least his agent
received that somebody received it he
now that he's home when quarantines got
time to read nothing but time to read
it's like this letter was actually
really sweet well done sir rethinking
this project you told me things that you
liked about Luther that I have yes
jaws the musical Bruce the musical Bruce
the musical about the making of Jaws
Jersey at the Paper Mill Playhouse in
New Jersey 2021
I guess this somewhat I don't call it
dower
but it is a awakening I think of sorts
okay is that diamond distributors which
in comic books is the only way that
stores get merchandise yes oh it is it
is out of Baltimore
out of Baltimore Diamond is it that's
how you get comic books if you're a
comic book retailer I am a comic book
retailer a brick-and-mortar comic book
retailer Jay and Silent Bob's secret
stash located in beautiful downtown Red
Bank New Jersey currently closed due to
the pandemic and stuff so I'm very
familiar with the good folks done why
because diamond has stopped shipping
blast to brick-and-mortar stores yeah as
of the 23rd announced that it would
suspend new products until further
notice in response to a myriad of
economic regulatory and public health
concerns related to the Cova 19
situation in other words retailers -
like yourselves will have no supply of
new product and publish
very limited channels to bring their
periodicals to market oh my god that was
you know we were already working on when
I say we they are back home but I was
talking about with Carol like you know
picking up your books and and kind of
curbside and stuff but now we're not
gonna have any product to sell you know
I don't think so
until I mean look I'm not being
unreasonable and as much as I understand
comic books aren't in [ __ ] necessity
like food and medicine and stuff like
that but why are they stopping shipping
I'm just because of like pay trucks and
people and because they're packing
comics into boxes that people then touch
what I think it's certainly like you
know the way the comp industry works the
way I understand it is there were three
months out so it's like it's not like
they're like well there ain't no books
to sell right it's let me see here's a
statement from Steve jeppy Chevy runs
done we're hearing thousands retailers
they can no longer service their
customers say it again louder we are
hearing from thousands of retailers that
they can no longer service their
customers as they have in the past many
of them forced to close by government
action or resort to any person or
curbside delivery even though those
still open are seeing reduced foot
traffic in most cases a situation that
seems likely to worsen with time our
publishing partners are also faced with
numerous issues in their supply chain
working with creators printers and
increasingly uncertainty when it comes
to the production and delivery of
products for us to distribute our
freight networks are feeling the strain
and are already experiencing delays
while our distribution centers in New
York California Pennsylvania were all
closed late last week our owner home
office in Maryland is instituting a work
from home policy and experts say we can
expect further closures therefore my
only logical conclusion is to cease the
distribution of new weekly product until
there is greater clarity on the progress
made towards stemming the spread of this
disease
they went to clarify the retailers can
still replenish stock a perennial strong
sellers like graphic novels and games
through Dimond and its affiliate what
wait so you can get old stuff but you
just can't hold it up you can't get new
stuff I don't understand
but I think that that what is happening
already is gonna kill a bunch of common
bookstores right there it's all I mean
comic book stores I kill ours as a
business was already kind of on the
brink in lots of different as a retailer
I could say that thank God we got a
gimmick and as much as like you know Jay
and Silent Bob in our store has been
around for over 20 years at this point
is brick-and-mortar establishment and
stuff but we were already kind of like
is gonna hurt but you know there's a
certain amount of cushioning and we can
always do online stuff and whatnot but
without new product this might actually
yeah I think it's it's most stores most
might be an exaggeration but a majority
of stores I think we're like a majority
of Americans which were one or two
months away from finding themselves in
dire financial straits yeah and I think
that something like this and an event
that is going to take in some cases you
know generously weeks probably more
realistically months that is that is
just time that so many of these stores
just can't actually get back that
product to sell aren't gonna be able to
meet their rents are gonna be able to
make their mortgages aren't gonna be
able to pay their staffs and it's the
comic book brick-and-mortar industry has
already receded greatly over the last
ten years and this might be nobody wants
to call it like the death knell for an
industry but at the very least a
paradigm shift in the way comics works
yeah I'm glad you didn't lead with this
that's a cow bookstore owner [ __ ] oh my
god does the dream die soon like cuz
we've been you know making it work for
two decades but like is this how the
stash stops I mean I I think that it's
going to cause a lot of reexamination of
the comic book business itself like soup
to nuts which was already like we heard
rumors about there were you know who
owns Warner Brothers now 18t rumors for
the last few months that they are like
not interested in the comic book
division they fired Dan to do last month
and part of the reason they said was
then
where was the new DC rebirth whatever
[ __ ] called this time was gonna go
but another part of it sounds like they
were you know I saw some report rows
like they're thinking about selling the
comic book division to Marvel and I
don't think there's truth to that at all
but I do think you know AT&T is just
like look I understand we need these
licenses
I understand it's great to own Batman
and Superman but comic books why are we
publishing this is a loss leader not
even a leader it's just a loss so I yeah
this might be a time when they might use
this as an excuse to you know to [ __ ]
you know all the businesses that's been
hanging on you or the very least to
transform a business I've been hanging
on I mean and we've seen I like that
we've seen I'll be talking we've seen
other versions of this right like the
music business did not know how to
grapple with digital yeah and so went
through a drastic reinvention and
wuzzamboo there's a question so in a
world where diamonds like there'll be no
new books
what about digital can you still get new
comics digitally yeah absolutely and I
think from what I understand Marvel and
DC are still actively in production mode
they're still like paying artists to
draw this you are [ __ ] hitting they
not that they're like encouraging it but
I think I'm saying like the people are
still gonna be able to get their comics
yeah I mean I think is technically
comiXology was always an outlet and
while diamond is the only game in town
for paper books you can still read your
books on comiXology the DC app marvel
absolute stuff there's still avenues for
you to get your copy look I wouldn't
want to be in the position Steve
jeppesen but hanging a businessperson
I'm sure he's like [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] bills and no money coming in
blah blah blah but you know that's your
the only game in town
and if you let people realize oh I'm
free without having to pick up comic
books every week like I never thought I
could be this person they might you know
be my it might be hard to convince them
to come back yeah I mean I think that
that you know Digital has been making
like vast inroads and yeah and the
readership is increasingly growing
because the delivery method is
instantaneous and easy and you could
subscribe and read everything you've
ever wanted to read with a Marvel
unlimited subscription or DC has their
own version of that where for a monthly
fee like Netflix everything on a library
you have access to remember man this is
a culture where we saw in our lifetime
people give up photo albums
nobody [ __ ] keeps photo albums
anymore nobody prints our pictures Kodak
[ __ ] died because nobody prints out
photos anymore because you got an app
where you can collect the money but I'm
all up I'm [ __ ] Instagram or
something like that so it might be a
world where people like oh I just read
my comics here and have to worry about
banning them picking out the perfect
book and [ __ ] bagging I'm boarding it
yeah our priority has shown with both
music and movies and DVDs we have
shifted from a 1/2 culture to we have
access culture I don't need to have the
thing anymore I just need to know that I
can watch it what I'd like to mmm I need
to know that I can read it when I want
to we're listening to it when I have to
like Spotify doesn't rise the way it has
if it was I need to own this albums like
no just listen what I want to listen
it's true and I think that that I don't
think comics will ever go away I don't
think the print edition will ever go
away I think it becomes vinyl I think it
becomes a thing that there's a bunch of
purist who still love and we will pay
exorbitant sums of money to get our
hands on but it no longer becomes a
computer consumer media the way that it
had been and in that regard I think that
stores like the stash can still exist
because they're still vinyl stores
there's still a collector's market for
that that's true verified boutique II
like a record store where you're gonna
go in and go like well I ain't expecting
to buy a record for 12 bucks I'm
probably gonna have to buy a record for
50 or 75 yeah and the comic books might
like you know they'll do like what was
that Detective 1000 was not like a 10
dollar book or something maybe that
becomes the standard like every book is
ten bucks I mean maybe they just don't
publish floppies anymore maybe it's all
trades maybe all the floppies go online
you show up to the store you get your
twelve dollar trade and that's it that's
the way you know and if you really want
a floppy maybe they'll make one for you
for 25 bucks print on demand if you
well that's it though like we're doing a
limited run of 1000 yeah and if you get
it you get it
best card stock in the world best paper
stock in the world and it would be like
think about that what a boon that would
be I think and I'm sure someone online
will correct me but wouldn't that be a
boon for a comic book store market to
suddenly have like every week is a chase
book every week is a chase book but is
the audience there to support you only
need this many about its right like it
becomes your your your drastically
shrinking the number of stores but the
ones that remain can be somebody you're
not Starbucks anymore
you're now like oh there's one version
of the store in your state you know in
your city where you gotta go find it and
so I it's it's bad for those small
business owners clearly like the
coronavirus is awful for almost every
business owner yeah but it's you know
not to say that there's opportunity in
it but there is a there's going to be a
sort of reexamining of this particular
business model as well as lots of other
business models you know like JC was
telling us like 50% of the bars and
restaurants in LA are going to close
let's talk to a real [ __ ] store owner
and stuff somebody boots on the ground
JC you come on talk about the [ __ ]
don't touch my [ __ ] we're bouncing the
beat the content to the fans like the
bat-signal in Batman Returns like off
mirrors and Gotham what what have you
heard as a boots-on-the-ground
restaurant tour you've had to be closed
I mean we yeah we closed two weeks ago I
think and like the day before it was
mandated and it's uh I mean it's scary
we're on Hollywood Boulevard our rent is
astronomical yeah we're paying over
seven hundred dollars a day in rent that
were closed
to do so without anything coming in with
nothing coming in and I think thankfully
for
the employees here they just passed the
bill they're gonna hopefully get really
good unemployment benefits for a few
months but unless there's something to
do with rent relief or something there
it's it's a lot of money if we're closed
to May or June until this thing subsides
and then we've got to hope that people
will come back out that they're not
scared to go out that being said you're
not one of these cats that's like [ __ ]
let's open up on Easter and [ __ ] like I
would rather be safe I mean even the
week before we were supposed to close
nobody was here it was dead right like
you know you had like one guy here one
guy there this is gonna be the new
fashion what you need to do is make a
lot of scum and villainy branded [ __ ]
rubber gloves everybody comes in gets
rubber gloves and [ __ ] cuz for the first
few months after this [ __ ] you know
everyone this could be like the [ __ ]
day new ma of an alien invasion movie
where the people are still like oh
there's one still killing [ __ ] months
after the [ __ ] fact people are still
gonna be like [ __ ] Charms they're
everywhere so you rubber gloves man
they're gonna be that there's gonna be
the [ __ ] rave inside on it's gonna be
it's gonna be slow-mo confusing and
baffling and why is everybody just is
this still the matrix yeah man those
cats were not socially isolated no no no
all right what else we got man um let's
see we have we have one last story which
is also not all that rosy but if I got
another sad story like your comic book
business is done for and you're out of
the movie business come here for this I
could have told you that 20 years ago
but no Stuart Gordon oh this is sad this
is sad the filmmaker who made
the animator from beyond from beyond
Robo jocks robot jocks robe I mean he
was on little people in giant robots
decades before getting a Pacific Rim
like he was in for EM it was and robot
jocks if you guys haven't seen it I'm
gonna be sure we can find it but it's
ridiculous and amazing yeah all of his
movies were I didn't see the in the arts
my friend Vincent said that he made a
bunch of really interesting indie films
III didn't see those I'd see the science
fiction movie called fortress
starring Christopher Lambert and I did
see [ __ ] space truckers with Stephen
Dorff
I remember space truckers as well god
that's going back yeah and he also wrote
Abel Ferrara's body hunters oh and
that's a good excuse I'll tell you right
now man like I really identify with this
cat because like he passed he was how
old he was but 72 72 a big long life not
long enough particularly for a genius
like that who gave us such joy but I
read I read all his stuff and as I read
it I'm like oh this is what's gonna be
like when I die because it's gonna be
it's like you know he had he worked his
whole life he made a bunch of things but
everyone's like the [ __ ] movie where
the guy takes his [ __ ] head and then
eats the oh come on meant like that's
his clerks like [ __ ] he will like no
matter what he did for the rest of his
life people like Rihanna made her bro
reanimate her I know I know that was
such a [ __ ] amazing wild movie I
tweeted today I was like there you don't
get to tuskor i don't get to test
without reanimate her and i'm sure some
people are like well then [ __ ] i wish
you hadn't seen but yeah [ __ ] stuart
gordon man what a legend i'm it's not
the sole reason but part of the reason I
do what I do is because he did what he
did yeah I mean he was part of that wave
of filmmakers in the in the 80s
specifically the 80s who were working
for like you know Cannon Films and
golan-globus and just making you know
flock with love like
ramie was one of those guys yeah
grinding out these sort of exploitation
movies because he loved him because and
you could tell interesting stories in
them until somebody was like we'll give
you a lot of money stop grinding yeah
dude you can I make it and start making
a spider-man yeah speaking of which we
haven't really even spoke about this but
Sam Raimi good direct Doctor Strange -
that means like that's nuts yeah that we
live in that world where Sam Raimi's
coming back into Marvel but a different
Marvel than the Marvel he left and he's
big Ditko guys so him he's done Spidey
now he gets to do Doctor Strange and I
love scott derrickson I love the movie
that he made and stuff so I'm not like
you know this is a step up but [ __ ] yeah
Sam Raimi and if it's what is it the
multiverse of madness yep one of the
rumors going around online and we gotta
be careful this is a rumor I knew
nothing I know nobody kids anytime we
say [ __ ] people like Kevin Smith
confirmed yeah look I'm confirming some
[ __ ] fantasy [ __ ] I read online
and I'm like ooh that would be cool
somebody was theorizing that like if Sam
Raimi is directing it and it's a
multiverse
can you get Toby to come back as a
spider-man or Peter Parker you know what
I'm saying like that would be [ __ ]
crazy
like would and we've seen their
willingness to you know like Jay jonah
Jameson is the same Jay jonah jameson
from rama's flicks yeah I mean but my oh
my only hesitation would be don't
hesitate support it is that into the
spider-verse did that so well yes so
well that they moved the big grown-up
movies that aren't cartoons like the
live-action movies you know they're
gonna be like it worked there let's
[ __ ] take this [ __ ] and do it here
that way we can like have a thousand
spider-man's and [ __ ] we can have one
spider-man every month but a man spider
month but yes Stuart Gordon our AP
absolute legend man if you haven't seen
reanimate ER in a red-hot minute let's
all watch it tonight
maybe not together go home get high and
watch reanimate go look let's be honest
I'm
there's no mic to it I'm gonna go home
with hi but what I do what I watch the
thing and I think we animator might be
on the mini he was also and I didn't
know this the co-creator of the Honey I
Shrunk the Kids franchise yes he wrote
the original draft of Honey I Shrunk the
Kids which you know also multi-talented
guy man again like you know everyone's
like reanimate or and rightfully [ __ ]
so we animator is is akin to that
episode of you know the cartoon episode
the short the Bugs Bunny short where
Daffy and bugs are competing and Daffy
it's like now I'm gonna eat this poison
now I'm gonna eat this dynamite and now
when he blows up and he's like what a
great [ __ ] show that he's like I can
only do it once
like mr. Kratz it's so [ __ ] tough to
like get past that and I remember as a
kid like going [ __ ] reanimate er and
then when he did from beyond I was like
the same [ __ ] guy and he's also doing
an HP Lovecraft and it was good but like
nothing will ever touch reanimate erm an
same like and again I'm comparing myself
to the guy only in as much as I know
that feeling of like I like the first
one
thank you you know I've made a bunch of
them since but whatever that I'm glad
you liked them anyway let me see that
shelf in walrus movie - don't know what
doesn't matter as long as you like black
and white one that's totally fine I will
say that if you're gonna get high honey
I show the kids is also a pretty decent
pick not bad what's our coat what the
[ __ ] is with that act and a so
imaginative man in terms of like you
know [ __ ] it's it's the thing that
it's so cinematic in as much as like I'm
an adult man and that cheerios [ __ ]
huge like that captures your imagination
in such a wonderful way I mean I you see
did we get to talk about Invisible Man I
haven't seen it yet he tell you
something about the Invisible Man okay
it made a lot of money and [ __ ] so
obviously I'm not [ __ ] hipping you to
something like you gotta see it well
obviously you got to see now you're
gonna see it got no place else to go so
[ __ ] good Leigh Whannell has I'm
watching this movie like because they
you know seven million bucks big big-ass
Universal movie seven million bucks I'm
watching the movie and I'm like you know
it is a cheap movie to make if one of
your main care
doos is just not there the cheapest
special effect in the world to be liked
is he here and it's like sure and then
he put his string on a chair and pull
halfway through the movie they get into
some more effects and stuff because I'm
telling you the story teller the
ingenuity of how the guy's invisible
impressed me no [ __ ] end cuz I don't
remember the ones from childhood or like
the black-and-white one but like was a
Claude Rains yeah this woman how do you
get invisible as potion a serum it was
always like blood look where you live in
a different world now where it's like no
serums gonna [ __ ] make it invisible
but there's pseudoscience they came up
with those like well that's [ __ ] blah
that's it they must be working on that
right now
really [ __ ] imaginative I saw onward
we marked weed we texted because I put
up a you know [ __ ] guys live stream live
is like Oh keV you should have told I
don't warned you me it was like I should
have warned you about aah oh my god if
you've had a first she going to it gone
like if you've ever had a dad there's
gonna be a nut biter of a movie because
about a dead if you have a dead dad's
even bigger of a nut biter in the movie
and then you find out and third act
Jarrod's about dads but it's really
about having a brother having a sibling
but specifically having a brother and
it's very specifically about having an
older sibling that [ __ ] destroyed me
I called up my brother he started
selling a bunch of text I'm shooting the
movie me like I was like you have to
[ __ ] watch this he's like we were
gonna watch it man exam and Jerry's
husband they love Disney so he's like
but based on your reaction I'll I'll
watch it sooner and then he [ __ ]
texted me after he watched and he was
like oh my god I understand why it's
such a beautiful movie so well done and
they do some [ __ ]
spoilers like see the movie we're gonna
spoil it a little bit as a storyteller
how [ __ ] impressed were you with the
resin with I want to spoil it too much
yeah I mean the movie we're driving
towards one specific thing yeah your
main character telling don't tell what
it is but yeah it's I want to do this
thing that has been I've never gotten to
do before
and through this weird as magical thing
I'm going to have my chance yes to get
the thing I've always wanted and that's
the movie they sold us and a movie
they'd give you for most of the time
you're on a journey going this little
kid is finally see it in the [ __ ]
trailer the young brother is finally
gonna meet his dad and the older brother
it's it's they implied in the trailer
like he had met my dad he was around
when that before the dad died yeah so
yeah the younger kid that Tom Holland
character was a baby when the father was
born has no memories whatsoever of that
guy but the older brother which is Chris
Pratt is like yeah no I was like six or
seven when he passed away so I have all
these memories he's like I've got three
memories then later on he's like I've
got four yeah and the fourth one it's
heartbreaking
yeah the fourth one I hate but yeah and
so you're driving towards an end but you
think it's coming and even if you get
that ending would be totally satisfying
for you but then it doesn't do it it
doesn't do it in a way that is like
heartbreaking and beautiful it's yeah
and a brilliant choice like especially
the moment they've been building toward
the perspective on that moment is just
nothing short of fantastic
and it takes so much to subvert an
audience an audience's expectation for
that moment you've been on this journey
the whole [ __ ] time going like we're
gonna [ __ ] see this guy yeah and that
they they they give you that they
deliver on the promise but in such an
extraordinarily generous and unforeseen
way that instantly the movie took
[ __ ] I and I was already in but it
took a couple [ __ ] jumps where I was
like as a writer I was like I I'm in
this business I try to be as
manipulative as the rest with my
storytelling I did not [ __ ] see that
coming and I'm so glad that that was the
movie that gave me as opposed to the one
that I assumed that I was gonna see
which was good enough don't get me wrong
but the [ __ ] in the third act they
were like oh you think that's the movie
this is the movie and suddenly look
it reminds me a little bit and maybe
more than a little bit of frozen the end
of frozen does similar things this is
really I still have never seen frozen um
then I'm not gonna spoil it for oh no
I'm now I might watch it during the
quarantine yeah like what once you get
past the whatever inbred barnacle in you
have over you know the [ __ ] song I
love the song let it go which is a great
song but it'll be nice to see what the
context is oh oh that's what she wants
to let go whole time I've been hearing
this I don't know what it was doesn't
have herpes because now I'm really
[ __ ] curious ice herpes
it does it does drive to a similar place
where you're like oh this is it's a
romance but not that it's I don't know
nothing about except that song and Olaf
the snowman because everyone's like
didn't you Olaf clerks but yeah they do
that similar sort of thing where it
doesn't give you the movie you want it
gives you the movie you need and you
could not have seen that coming except
you totally could if you should know oh
it's great I literally I thought of you
and I watched that movie I was like that
something mark Bernard would do where
you thought you were doing this but
instead you're doing this like that's
great [ __ ] story tonight something I
would've tried definitely worth a watch
once again any time I say something I
put up a tweet about [ __ ] uh hey I
watch birds of prey and it's fun flick
and I like this bow meticulous Benzema
buggers like you're a [ __ ] chill a
dirty [ __ ] [ __ ] shell like I
like [ __ ] to nobody but nobody pays me
to [ __ ] say I like movies man like I
wish they did particularly now as the
business shuts down what a great way to
make a living that would be just be like
I like [ __ ] there's a cameo for movie
studios but that will just pay you to
just come on your phone and be like you
know what I really liked I really like
[ __ ] onward thumbs up on this I think
the III don't know why it is man I I am
i you call I am a shill on the level of
I just like things that I like I will
happily tell you about all this [ __ ] I
like and nobody has to pay me a [ __ ]
dime to do it and they don't I promise
you if that was the thing I know there
are influencers in this business and
[ __ ] but if I could get a [ __ ] dime
Marvel or DC to talk about their movies
you don't think I [ __ ] tell you about
it oh my god I'd be the most clever
[ __ ] in the world I just talk about
the [ __ ] because I love this [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I love it when it's well done
and stuff and great storytelling that
make I'm a grown-ass man I know
everyone's like you Kroy to put a drop
back I'm a grown-ass man who knows how
the sausage is made and still if you
could [ __ ] rip open my heart and I
was in that world with those [ __ ] I
don't even know what they were elves or
whatever think so I was I bought it hook
line and sinker and [ __ ] and if you
could do that I'm happily sing about
that to the rooftops particularly now
when we're all stuck inside like who
don't want to feel good about like
watching something [ __ ] cool and [ __ ]
like that but it has nothing to do
somebody give me money trust me that is
not a real job kids like I know people
like on the internet or like I have a
lot of assumptions about Hollywood and
some of them could be true I guess but
like let me tell you something I've been
trying I've been trying hard to get this
job where they give you money to say
like nice things about movies it doesn't
exist as far as I know we just do this
for free yeah yeah I mean I think for as
many people that think that you get paid
to say you like things people think that
I hate everything that's true
they do they do Twitter they're always
like oh [ __ ] it you know Sue's like we
put a between like we're gonna talk
about this look I'm sure mark [ __ ] on it
Kevin loves it too much I'm like oh my
god do we have do we have stereotypes
already but it's not true mark loves so
many things it's just I don't like yeah
then you're gonna [ __ ] hear and also
by comparison I like everything
so we gonna mark like I'll be like I'll
blow something for a half an hour and
Billy it was amazing
mark and marks like yeah here's the
truth it may be my truth but it's the
truth
remember on the Tami show it was a
teenage American music something
something it was the 1960s concert that
somehow managed to rope in every [ __ ]
music I've had mattered and the the most
important version of this is that there
was a big it was like a three-day
festival
and the final two acts were going to be
either James Brown or the Rolling Stones
and so then they like tried to figure
out who's gonna [ __ ] be the final
closing act and ultimately the Rolling
Stones like they won well there was a
coin toss or a dice roll or whatever the
[ __ ] it was rolling stones one was a
James Brown's like all right you're the
closing act fine and that he goes on
stage and tears the roof off the place
like makes it impossible to follow like
he's [ __ ] doing splits and he's
moonwalking and he might be floating I'm
not sure and he's like he thinks he got
capes we don't have any [ __ ] capes
and then the rest of the concert ends
and James Brown's like alright follow
that and they do and they just do their
[ __ ] like Rolling Stone [ __ ] I feel
like that sometimes when you like
slobber all over something say mark
story was like dude did I [ __ ] smoke
away the beginning oh I'm James Brown
James Brown I have a cape you totally
have a [ __ ] cape it's the best part
of that story spangly in heels you're
like white prince III feel that way
about you many times I felt that way
when I came back in January because you
had been like doing the show while I was
away and I got behind the bar and you
were so sharp and I was like ah Star
Wars right people like Star Wars right
yeah that that is I think somehow at the
end of the news that's all the news hey
man do you want to jump on and tell your
story or no cuz you're like the only
person in the world that like I know
that it's gone through an experience
that the whole world is wondering about
we put her in this put her in the slot
where she go and sit where on the other
side of the table on the other side I
knew it over on the other side PJ this
is which name you wanna go but this is
the launch got a bunch gotta let her
Guffey and like nineteen aliases PJ
Philon
she works in the industry with us one of
the things she does amongst many things
she does is what do they call it when
it's four dudes grooming men's grooming
say hello to everybody at home I've
worked with Philon on and off for years
six years she worked with method on what
was that show called chop the mic and
stuff which was part of the reason we
got method into Jay and Silent Bob repo
so red red is her nickname in the
business because she her name is Philon
and she feels a lot of people [ __ ] it up
so she just goes with the easy I'm red
and so everyone kind of goes with that
red who have you been shooting with this
weekend you've shot with this cat for a
while
into the microphone okay so red shoots
with Larry King Larry King old is Larry
King killed damn so the great Larry King
who I've interviewed with many times
wonderful journalists 86 gonna be 87
clearly in the yeah the dangers of the
danger zone high risk indeed but wants
to continue being who he is doing doing
the news but he don't want to stop but
his is more important because he
actually talks to like political leaders
and [ __ ] we're like you know what
happened on the mail or iam I'm James
Brown yes you're James pray so how many
people on the crew must be skeleton crew
at this point so rightfully so so he's
working from home like the rest of us
Larry is okay this is what I found
fascinating because we live in a country
right now we live in a world where a lot
of people are like do I have the
coronavirus how would I know can I get a
test and testing is not as up and
running no as far as I know I've been
maybe I'm having reading the right
articles but I don't think you can just
get tested the demand
raise the supply Philon has been tested
because in order to work with Larry tell
the story in order to work with Larry
his son makes you well he doesn't make
you he gives you the option of taking
the kovat 19 test because Larry is such
a high risk so he surprised us one day
when we got to set and he said hey guys
we had access to the test and in order
to you know I would appreciate it if you
could take it before working with my
father since he's such high risk of
course that was very shocking cuz it was
a it's a blood test it's not like a
mouth swab
I guess there's different types of tests
it's a budget this is the thing let's
break break it down for number one like
it's hysterical you at the mascot she's
not trying to hide our identity it's
just like we stumbled like a narc le
document no it's it's it's you know the
coronavirus alright so what is the what
is the tip what it look like come in a
box ah I cut you with a razor yeah look
I don't know anything about STD tests
but the thing that like most diabetics
have to do when they test their blood my
dad my dad his whole life was always
pretty on his finger that thing so they
did that to you it was just smart to do
if you're [ __ ] working with somebody
who's high-risk that's better microphone
so I would have been like are you
kidding me I like I'll do it for the
time cuz I'm afraid of needles right
even poking I just I'm just
uncomfortable unless I you know want it
but you know build up to it unless you
wanna like sometimes I like to do heroin
so even that's when I like a pokin
saying I wasn't I wasn't warmed up
because they didn't tell us beforehand
that that was an option that was gonna
be offered to us so were you scared to
take the test yeah why face it like the
feeling that I felt was like an unwanted
pregnancy test like you know what I mean
kind of like I want it to be negative
but what if it's positive sort of
situation so that's what I was basically
dealing with but also to was just like I
said my phobia of just blood needles and
everything look at you I can't explain
the feeling but it was like but then at
the same time it was like wow we're
being offered something that a lot of
people aren't getting and we should see
this as like you know a blessing so it
was so many emotions so I don't want to
take it forgetting like oh my god you
know I'm afraid of needles blah blah
like I was thankful it's just they just
threw it on us you had no idea was that
but that to me with the most shocking
part of the story was I was like you
took the test I mean like people in
Larry people in government haven't taken
the test yet like you see like
governor's going like we don't have the
test and PJ was like oh I took the test
I'm like what I was like did you study
so and you came up I was negative yes I
was negative you find out within 10 to
20 minutes it's I guess it's this new
testing that a South Korean doctor came
up with and apparently he shipped a
whole bunch of units over here to the US
and it's the fastest don't quote me on
anything but because any time any story
I've read it was like somebody went in
and got a test I stopped isolating and
when they're told yes you do but like
you find out within 10 to 20 minutes and
the whole entire time I was staring at
that I was just laser heating the corona
way really like if this comes up over
you know you don't know what's true
happen so like I said it was all types
then that's when like the moment like
thank you for offering the test and you
know what I mean that came in after the
panic and it's nice to know that there's
a different version the test that we had
been told which was the swab that they
stick like up your nose and like deep
into you I think I'm like scraping the
inside of your skull to get to you like
I much rather just prick a finger sounds
you got the test that's better than a
lollipop I bet you people would pay like
a lot of money to get the test yeah
apparently people are like charging for
it it's ridiculous pouring it on like I
bet you if you went to like eBay or
something like that but it's active you
can even [ __ ] like that test is only
18 dollars only costs 18 bucks they
charge you for it take the test now give
us 18
I mean I haven't even heard of anybody
taking the test because as far as I knew
I don't know anybody who's taking right
you were literally the first person yeah
you are the unicorn you're the first
person I've heard of that has taken the
test you're the only person that I know
for sure doesn't have Corona Wow you
guys should work for Larry Kingman yeah
that's the point of this story
Larry interview and it better be
important people dr. drew is love lines
dr. drew a doctor is a doctor but
apparently there was a speculation
whether or not he was for the corona
quarantine or not apparently there was
people saying that he was like it's a
bunch of BS
whoo so that's why they had him on the
show dr. Drew was earlier saying wasn't
a coded denial
exactly exactly it was a question that's
a thing right covert denier I mean our
president is a covert denier who's like
the word open in the country in time for
Easter and everybody's like dude don't
do that that's
a bad idea packing a bunch of people in
the church that sounds like a bad idea
Irene article are you guys quarantine or
what is this like tape the tape we
obeying this whenever week off we do it
wait a second I read an article in New
York Times today about a lady whose
husband got covin and she became
full-time nurse her and her daughter and
it sounds [ __ ] horrible
yeah like really bad like you know cuz
when we hear about it we're all like we
don't want to get at the pandemic these
are the numbers but this was a woman
boots on the ground talking about like
he can't move he has to lay on his
[ __ ] side he today he took a piece of
an orange and [ __ ] and oranges are so
rare it's an exotic fruit at this point
like she had to take him to the hospital
they live in New York City so they had
to bundle him up and shuffle down the
street he couldn't [ __ ] even move and
it sounds [ __ ] like beyond miserable
and he is he's considered high-risk
because he's got a like asthma or
something like that but man I don't want
to you know a lot of people like if I
get it I get it
I don't want [ __ ] I don't want this at
all it ain't like getting a flu or cold
it's taken people [ __ ] down man like
hardcore not like the picture they
painted early on was it'll be just like
the flu like you'll get a high fever but
you can weather it it's only if you're
super young no super old but one of my
friends tested positive for it today
what yeah where'd they get a test what
friend famous now he's a producer
producer there you go me and getting no
test because we in Elite enough but no
he's he had flu-like symptoms though yet
symptoms yeah that's the thing you
should only really be like worried about
the test he's 54 years old and he took
the test and he tested positive okay my
kid yesterday was just like I you know
[ __ ] I got the shits I'm like I don't
think that's
my brother and his wife are expecting a
baby now in New York congratulations
like yeah great but like within the next
two weeks
oh so there's hard to find a hospital I
mean but like at the moment well okay
about it right because yoshi's tends to
be early it's gonna be their second
child but if it was like if she was five
months pregnant then they would just be
panicked like more than they already are
panicked but there aren't two weeks
maybe we can get in before the crazy
rushed to hospital bed starts and maybe
they're saving you know the maternity
wards because there are you know
probably somewhere between a million and
five million bucks right at home birth
or that home birth which he doesn't want
to do because he's not that cat the I
saw in New York as well since we're on
the New York subject one of my favorite
hotels in the world
Four Seasons Hotel the I am pipe a
design building I'm 57 they are donating
their room because nobody's [ __ ]
staying and nobody traveling anyway
they're donating their rooms to all the
doctors nurses and people working like
in the hospitals there in the city so
they could work go spend the night in a
really nice [ __ ] hotel rooms these
rooms like 2,000 bucks a night and [ __ ]
that is coming together especially in a
world where it's like it's no skin off
their ass like we got an empty building
[ __ ] man if that's gonna help there's
gonna help and stuff we're gonna see a
lot of things probably get turned into
temporary hospitals and [ __ ] they were
talking about in New York they're
looking at the Javits Center yeah also
which makes all the sense of the world
because you're in a conference but it
looks a lot like that Steven Soderbergh
movie Contagion once you start taking
big [ __ ] rooms and putting beds and
[ __ ] yeah I don't know if you saw that
movie mark but it didn't really work out
well for a lot of [ __ ] people I
remember seeing that movie years ago and
their big marketing hook was like you
know the human the average human touches
their face 3,000 times a day and [ __ ]
back then it was like oh that's [ __ ]
up now
yeah it's terrifying no Stephen King put
up the audio book chapter of the stand
where which is all about the drips of
captain shred of captain truth which is
which as I remember it you know living
in New York at the time riding the
subway reading a chapter about a dude in
a subway you coughs
everybody in that subway car is dead and
I'm like [ __ ] don't do that to
me
oh let's let's not hope let's hope that
we don't get anywhere close to the
Lincoln Tunnel seen in that book Oh God
heroin I forgot about captain trips I
was thinking about the other day the
army of the 12 monkeys mmm you know
everyone goes for Planet of the Apes
because of the ending of that movie and
stuff but the same time like army of the
12 monkeys man at the end of 12 monkeys
the guy opens the [ __ ] pathogen and
[ __ ] in the in the airport yes we're
Brad Pitt just like monkey one of his
greatest performances he should have
want to [ __ ] Supporting Actor for
that movie yes nominated but didn't he
was nominated but he should have won all
right give it up for a full-on man
she told us some [ __ ] information that's
literal [ __ ] this Batman nonsense that's
useful information like who knew that
their tests thank you for yeah thank you
we're gonna we're gonna swap you out
with JC bye guys
cuz he's gonna now ask us the ques we we
went online on Twitter and we went on
Instagram and we gave you a hash tag
riddle me this fat man and told you to
ask us questions now we're gonna do some
questions man JC has picked a bunch
I'm sure while we've been yammering and
he has been moving cars he doesn't have
a lot to do as you could see nobody's
[ __ ] here so I believe he's got the
questions ready man you ready for the
Q&A portion of the show I am ready
we're giving out prizes too man we have
got cars walk with a [ __ ] car never
mind these 40x screenings folks you're
giving away legit [ __ ] prizes but oh
well maybe next time alright what are
the hit us with a question JC how many
do you took a man took a mask off
off-camera you Batman [ __ ] well how many
do we want to do is go ten okay we've
got at junior was here on Twitter okay
asks as a writer wait what at Junior
@jr was here oh I was gonna psyche how
the [ __ ] this guy got jr. he's nice have
been like one of the first tweeters ever
I think he's a what dynasty fan yeah Jay
are you ink right oh maybe hojae he
asked as a writer what are your favorite
traits of jean-luc Picard I'm gonna let
ya I'm gonna let em handle that one go
favorite traits of jean-luc Picard I
mean you know what I'm gonna give this
to him solo I'm gonna clear the set
give him a [ __ ] single over there
what I'm gonna go forget move over space
my favorite traits of jean-luc Picard I
think I think jean-luc Picard when he is
at his best is very much like Steve
Rogers and their John of the card
believes he believes in the best in
everybody around him he believes in the
capacity for everybody to be excellent
around him he believes in Starfleet in
the same way that that Steve Rogers
believes in America and I think that
that he lives by a code and will never
stray from that code so basically yes
jean-luc Picard is the Captain America
of the Star Trek universe and and I do
love him so that was this great answer
Marc won a pair of I got gloves rubber
gloves little late cuz you've been
touching everything but put them on wait
everybody in the chat very happy about
that
very look before you put them on I saw
some some that pump [ __ ] where is that
that hand cleanse it's the new porn
right here this is the [ __ ] money
shot we all watch me put some [ __ ]
juice on my hands squeeze it into a
glove kill them germs buddy
Gabriel P from the YouTube chat was I
wanted to know would you be interested
in working on the Ninja Turtles
franchise and they think you guys would
be a perfect fit for it having worked
now on the Masters of the Universe
franchise yeah I think I would have a
good time playing with the turtles years
ago I don't think I could have said that
but now I'm like
oh I think I know how to play with other
people's toys in a way where I can
satisfy that audience and myself as a
storyteller and more importantly my
bosses the people that hire me to do
this too so I could I could see getting
my head around that what about you yeah
leave that yeah yeah don't use that pin
use that gloved hand didn't it feel
great like you like I can't wait to
drive Ryan Gosling in that movie called
drive yes you're right that's what I'll
feel like tonight when I'm going home
I'll just be like brooding and [ __ ]
what is the could you do a turtles can I
do a turtles would you could you in a
box would you could you with a fox I
think I could and I think I would but I
think that you know that my Turtles were
the Turtles from the original comic book
Eastman and Laird black-and-white books
yeah I mean it was and I didn't know
when I was a kid that it was just a play
on daredevil I thought it was just a
serious darkest [ __ ] grin Jack
[ __ ] I've ever seen and they were
fans they wrote [ __ ] fanfiction yeah
and we built an empire yeah cuz it's the
foot instead of the hand and there are
more [ __ ] turtle stories in the world
than there are stories about Jesus you
know what I'm saying think about that
[ __ ] the turtles Bibles thick as a
dick and the Bible Bible is no King
James but they're you know buggin it's
unfortunately Jesus dies early on right
makes it to like 33 eda those turtles
they've been around for as long Jesus
the Ned Stark of the Bible don't piss
everybody straight I know I mean don't
piss off the game of Thrones
alright that's good what else we got
that's two questions
that's two down two here comes the third
yes at JM Bolton asked do you think the
post corona film industry will open up
opportunities for smaller budget and
smaller crude productions one more time
slowly not the first pot but do I think
the will it open up opportunities for
smaller budget and smaller
productions with smaller crews I work in
this business you would imagine I have a
thought about that I don't know I don't
know if why would it make it easier or
open it up more I think they just it
showed that people can work from home
you can do things on a shoestring that
you know before we always knew that I
mean that's the thing it's like the you
could be making stuff even but he's
talking about the film industry the film
industry I I don't honestly don't know
that it's gonna have that kind of effect
I mean the first effect you can kind of
see is the studio's would give a token
like hey let's make a smart movie here
let's make of this movie if they come
back it ain't gonna be none of that it's
gonna be like we got to make the big we
got to pay to rent so we're gonna
nothing but blockbusters so you know the
mid-range budget movie had kind of died
off and disappeared and stuff is mostly
moves to Netflix and streamers right now
I think it's gonna be more extreme you
know look indie film will never go away
as long as everybody has a dream but I
come on make a movie instead and so you
can do it so I don't think it's gonna
change the opportunities than indie
filmmakers will have but I do think the
business the studio's once they turn the
lights back on are gonna be like we want
only sure things now to be fair that's
all they ever want but there's been a
kind of like well you know we can make
this this couldn't be an oscar movie and
and I don't think you're gonna think
about that at all I think they're gonna
be like sequels remakes and reboots the
sure thing that we could count on money
[ __ ] cash in hand so we can rebuild
this crumbling business and kids if
we're out of it for quite some time but
I don't know that that I necessarily
makes it easier or better for indie
filmmakers you yeah I I simply agree
that I don't I don't think it changes
the way movies are made and who gets to
make movies I think that's always gonna
be you know its own weird paradigm of
yes the same 30 people yet to make giant
blockbusters and then everybody else is
going to be making small personal movies
and I think those will still be made
that you know all the blockbusters that
got pushed out of this year or is going
to be what we see coming up next anyway
even if it starts in August with Wonder
Woman or then Black Widow and then fast
and furious nine and then all these
things that got kind of scaled down the
pike are gonna be coming fast and
furious but I I think I think we're
going to see a wave of small independent
low-budget Quarantine movies hmm because
I think that it's it will be the thing
that's on people's minds and the the
shared experience right where people
gonna be like oh my god that's what we
did yeah we did the same thing when we
were a quarantine you're gonna see you
like your quarantine romances you like
quarantine serial killer movies like
your quarantine comedies and you want
and and honestly there you go he may be
on to something that's a cheap [ __ ]
movie cuz literally the whole movies
about stay the [ __ ] inside yeah and the
villain the monster you can't even see
it's [ __ ] tiny yeah I mean there was
there was a movie it's the next
Invisible Man the [ __ ] the the the
quarantine series of quarantine movies
that mark feels we're gonna be dropping
it's probably not wrong like it is a
very inexpensive story to tell you're
stuck in four walls and shits like doing
black box theater I I know what I'm
gonna start writing
there's a movie that came out it was a
Sundance movie I can't remember the
[ __ ] name of it but it was it was
about these two people in a house and
there was like a some kind of viral
outbreak everyone is it was LA and it
was just that I was in the house and
there was like plastic or how fast can
you put the plastic on the windows how
quickly can you you know seal off your
air-conditioning like what happens if
you know your wife or the person you're
now quarantined with it's not who you
thought they were maybe they had some
other job out in the world that was
maybe part of this like it was it was a
big [ __ ] suspends potboiler I
remember being pretty good but I came in
with a [ __ ] name of it for life for
me so sorry I even brought it up but
that feeling of someone online
tell us what Mark forgot see his pensive
yes totally and I didn't even smoke
anything but yeah I think there's
there's always that reaction to the
national mood where to your point
there's going to be lots of movies about
the great blue yonder
and about like gathering in places
there's gonna be a lot of like New
Year's Eve movies and wedding movies and
party movies and like look remember when
we could all be in a place together and
do a thing they're gonna be movies about
that yeah I think community is going to
be the thing that that movies will or at
least a decent chunk of the the sort of
swirl around movies is gonna be how do
we make people feel good about the thing
they were missing for that time which
was being with loved ones and being in
open spaces in like traveling and going
on [ __ ] vacation and like hitting a
theme park like I'd be surprised if
there's not a wave of like Disney Plus
movies about kids working in theme parks
again yes right at your doors I mean yes
and you pulled it up well done and right
all right next question question number
four okay we have let's go with Tiger
Tai hey tiger he said he wanted sri
germans say Street how do you think
they're going to introduce blade in the
MCU how will introduce blade in the MCU
well he's in the MCU or is he is he
belong to Marvel or is it part of Star
uh the spider-man unit of Marvel they
could if they wanted to slip them into
Morbius or introduce him by way of
Morbius if Morbius you know Jared Leto's
picture establishes them and then they
stick him in the next spider-man movie
maybe that's where you have your first
taste blade I mean may because this
spider-man 3 feels like and sound like
it sounds like but it feels like it
could be packed movie feels like there's
gonna be a bunch of villains going after
him could be a sinister six affair so
maybe they don't want to [ __ ] be like
at all so here's back to her blade which
sounds way [ __ ] more erotic but the
idea of like this is the first time I
bet you they'll want a first time um in
their own motion picture so if you're
not using Morbius gonna make a
suggestion yeah [ __ ] yeah
he's a gentleman a writer it is entirely
possible you heard it here first a thing
I'm making up there could very well be a
multiverse of madness that has vampires
in it that's true this multiverse of
madness could let a lot of things in
like mutinous and because Doctor Strange
is our vector into the occult and magic
anyway and whether vampirism in this
version the Marvel Universe is a
science-based thing or an actual
supernatural magic thing
technically Doctor Strange can also give
you both because he's a doctor who has
worked in science and has also knows a
bit about the supernatural and like
susan has blade from another dimension
or from ours it could very well be from
a another multiple L earthy how would
you feel about that if he wasn't from
our earth but a parallel earth I know we
got bigger things to worry about with
Corona but what how would you feel if he
was we feel pretty good about it
really I mean if you want him to be Mars
ma'am but if you if you do a thing if
you do the crisis on Infinite Earths
where they all become one then I want
them to do that I mean I wouldn't be
against if they did it and stuff but I
wanted to be on number one his origin it
begins in birth right [ __ ] his mother
mom gets bit by a vampire when she's
carrying him right so it can't be like
you know if he would have to be from
another dimension then otherwise they
gotta go back in time and be like no
vampire I guess they can do whatever
they [ __ ] one company's a genius he'll
figure this [ __ ] out yeah let me know
they're asking the wrong Kevin the right
mark for the wrong Kevin it would feel
weird though if suddenly you're like hey
Avengers you know that [ __ ] you've been
worrying about by the way also vampires
and like we didn't know there are
vampires should we have known they were
vampires
No so multiverse let you know like
vampires are in Avengers level world
threat yeah we're doing phantoms level
Shann manhandle that [ __ ] get all small
crawl up the butthole like we all wanted
him to do in [ __ ] endgame did you hear
that there's a butthole cut of cat's eye
listen there's many reasons to talk
about cats and maybe now more than ever
if the
I'm talk about the dumbass things about
cats really a lot of money got spent on
that movie there's a like why did they
kind of a quasi butthole cut apparently
when they did all the effects the
folding of the layer of fake fur they
put on gave the impression as it met in
a seam it gave the impression of like
[ __ ] so it's not like they were like
we're doing a cut but that's on that
Kaplan [ __ ] that got put an ass on
that guy it's just like it happened
along the way and so they were like they
would have to erase it from what I
understand so it's not truly like the
butthole cup where it's like oh look at
that stinky ass Brown and [ __ ] it's just
the special effects aren't [ __ ] fully
done it ain't the Snider cut let's be
honest like that's real the butthole cut
is a fantasy but I don't imagine special
effects are like like drawing aged a
loaf of bread clothes right where you're
like pulling fabric over like it's CG
like who's in there doing like [ __ ]
CG stretch that's how that [ __ ] works
and then just twisting it off it's just
it's a model and the model as they build
it that's it it does that and apparently
as they folded the fur around them
because they all wore of those [ __ ]
suits and [ __ ] it folded the seam of the
connection folded in such a way that
it's like it's not look like cats
[ __ ] it's like a very elaborate way
to explain one pervy animator I'm
putting buttholes and everything's like
gonna no I hope nobody [ __ ] finds out
there's a hole cut I showed all my
friends all right so wait what was the
aunt was how do we get there is that for
we're done with that was done with for
the right that blade was four blades for
the cat [ __ ] cut of cat five question
number five is from Shetland Shawn if
you could take any song and build a
movie around its lyrics which song would
it be and what would the plot be welcome
to The Black Parade bye bye
Michael romance MCR such an epic song
I'm building clerks three around that
song so this is actually a great
question for me
I know yeah I'm basically I'm just
that's I'm using that as my model all
right so that's mine what's yours
Blue Oyster Cult veteran of the psychic
wars oh I thought you guys they don't
fear the reaper what is veterans of the
second-worst is a story song yeah it's
it's about this like soldier who had
been fighting in this kind of like
post-apocalyptic war that apparently
only took place in the mind but it was
very like [ __ ] like you say me now a
veteran of a thousand circuit was man
energy is spent at last and my armor is
destroyed ain't much to look at and I'm
not too much to see wounds are all I
made but it's it's very sort of crimson
and it's it's like post-apocalyptic D&D
is what I think of when I hear that song
it's like speaking that was they had a
lot of D&D and onward yeah I was gonna
text Joe Manganiello be like if you
watched it but I'm sure he's probably
[ __ ] Cena by now there's so many stuff
that he couldn't be Chris Pratt cuz it
dude I'm right [ __ ] live this all
right so wait what was that
we did it now we're on a six six this is
from Matthew Cox hello
Cox what is your favorite line or
recurring joke in a movie it would be
similar to like 37 in a row for you but
not one that you've created not from one
of my movie correct
a runner if you will hmm you got one I
don't I don't when I was a kid it would
have been like we're on a mission from
God you know the Blues Brothers it's not
like that's a joke does that happen like
more than once these yeah oh it says it
at least like between I remember a Jake
test well me in the Lord we got an
understanding you're on a mission from
God it's not in a single movie but I
think the
we're too old for I'm too old for this
[ __ ] well it's definitely in a single
[ __ ] movie but it's a I don't think
you would more than once in that movie
but I know they do it throughout the
series or leave the weapon
yeah yeah they were the first ones to do
I'm getting too
they literally coined that phrase I
believe I don't think anyone in pop
culture had ever said I'm getting too
over this [ __ ] yeah until they did in
what to lethal weapon - the first one -
first one as well yeah we we were back
in a lethal weapon world we didn't even
talk about that they're making another
Lethal Weapon movie do you read that I
did not read that but that's awesome
it's crazy a dick Donner's directing it
dick Donner is like 90 years old the
dickish on Donner is he could ever be at
age [ __ ] 90 it's good I mean I know
you know people have feelings about Mel
and stuff I'm good
but I'm just happy to dick Donner's
making a movie with his friends I'm sad
that we're not sad but it's a bummer
that one of his friends I'm happy for
dick Donner man [ __ ] one last one
last why here it might be too late I've
read an article where the like they're
gonna make two of those back-to-back I
mean if you're gonna make two now's the
time to make two you ain't kidding well
it's probably been shut down for the
minute right because it yeah its corona
time all right what else we got
did we have that one that was six yeah
please
yeah I'm too old for this [ __ ] yes what
was mine yours was I'm on a mission from
God
Isaac yeah that would have been it when
I was a kid what is it I'm gonna have to
let that stand ma'am I mean I guess like
you'd go the Star Wars movies and be
like I got a bad feeling about this
we're like 1-1 3-8 kind of spans all
sorts of different things like numbers
Young Frankenstein deep cuts Paul very
nice like Wilhelm scream could be a fun
one that runs through a lot of movies
but but yeah all right that's enough of
an answer yeah
also again it's it's over a course of
movies less in one movie but I can do
this all day I can do this all day yeah
I know I know
[Music]
[Laughter]
alright so that was six or seven that
was six here comes question number seven
this is from C path 92 C path 92 if you
could if you could pick a DC movie for
Jon Favreau to direct what character
would what character would you choose
and who would Favreau play Superman
hands-down put a character that
wonderful in the hands of a storyteller
that wonderful everyone's always like
it's tough to crack the Superman code
he's too powerful
Jon Favreau can make a brilliant
Superman movie who would fabs play in
that movie Perry White easily DC movie
directed by Johnny faz I'm gonna go with
Blue Beetle ooh I'm gonna go Blue Beetle
and I think that I mean I could see it
with the Iron Man of it all Ted Kord
millionaire make it and he's [ __ ]
young and he's a teenager and you can
have all that kind of teen fun are you
doing the Jamie one that's behind me
Reyes one yeah I think that I know and I
don't smart yeah I don't know the book
well enough to know who you would play
but I'm sure there's a principal who
gives Jaime Reyes some [ __ ] for being a
superhero that that watching Johnny fans
oh man you let him be [ __ ] run down
Booster Gold we always get like
presented the god like Booster Gold
doesn't let it be fabs man that cuz
that's the guy who would use it [ __ ]
time to get back and I think that could
work that's awesome alright where we go
next that was number seven we're on
eight this is from the chat Matthew
Hutchison wants to know is there a movie
that Mark loves that Kevin doesn't like
movie that I love that you don't that's
a good question because it's definitely
like the other way it'd probably be
easier to do because mark hates
everything
what do you like that I haven't liked I
don't know because the thing is our
tastes are relatively well alive yeah
very much so we're about the same age we
come from about the same place
yeah like the same stuff yeah like it's
Venn diagram really lays right on top I
mean I'm sure finding a movie that you
love that I don't is easier it just has
to be about hockey I've never seen slap
shot what yeah I didn't see frozen so
there we are we're even there and scene
yeah I don't know it's hard because then
we just have to still like going down
the list of like yeah I like that was
there anything on your top ten list from
last year that I was like what no never
yeah I mean there's stuff you haven't
seen like I don't think you'd seen fast
color I know I still haven't but I but
nothing that was like you're out of your
mind that movie was terrible
yeah I got some flack for Hustler's from
me know from our other special guest who
was read you can mark crap about
hustlers you like that mark liked
hustlers enough to put on my top ten she
was like really you didn't like that
much I you actually liked the story I
actually liked the story quite a bit
the j.lo of it all doesn't hurt I've
still mush you have a great big I don't
I don't know if we can answer that like
a few days to figure out [ __ ] mark likes
that I don't all right next question
Wow you stumped this panel well this is
from question number nine question nine
from Kevin wall skog hello Kevin okay
then who should Keanu play in a Marvel
movie because you know it's going to
happen what a great question who should
Keano play and a marble Submariner
no more hands down hands down he should
[ __ ] play no more in a world where
Aquaman is played by Jason Momoa and
you're gonna do your own underwater here
on [ __ ] you got to set him apart
kion Oh as no more John in John wick
like performance cuz no more is just a
[ __ ] killer but he's Bennett that's
my pick
he probably wears more clothes than
Namor usually does true because you know
kiddos in pretty good shape yeah but
he's also not a spring chicken
no no more is always like in a onesie
yeah bro bikini body
he's banana boat he's a bit like sting
and dunes yeah I will kill him beautiful
fade all I see it is the tradies I want
to kill all right [ __ ] alright so who
can to play I you know I would have said
I would have said [ __ ] Reed Richards
oh I thought what I wanted John
Krasinski to do that I but I want
[ __ ] Tiger to do it like you to play
the part they're like you know I would
back that play did the the tweet was
something like if Reed Richards is
supposed to be a guy who was skips
dinner because he was 50 million science
experiments here's that guy I agree when
I saw that I was like oh my god that's a
great choice I hope I wonder if they're
thinking about that at all cuz he was
great IG 11 oh yeah like [ __ ] he's great
cold yeah yes he's already into you he
goes new master called me a dick I
he doesn't have big enough role but I
think that can also be an awesome
watcher wha - wha - Keanu as a wha - but
just that [ __ ] I was just gonna say that
man what about Ghost Rider Wow like if
they were like we're gonna do that [ __ ]
again that would be super cool Wow
Ghost Rider would have been played by
both Nick Cage and Keanu that makes that
part like [ __ ] Batman and
that's right on TV all right a lot sees
your answer watches my answer I like my
answer more it's better last question
ten of ten all right this is from
William Curtis kind of a silly one if
you were in the masked singer
what would your costume be do you get to
pick your costume
oh he's asking what would you like sonna
Bob big big furry silent bob character
mascot likes when I took the head off
they're like you're [ __ ] kidding it
was okay you couldn't figure it out so
I'm about and the idea of a big Silent
Bob singing is kind of funny in and of
itself I think even though your mouths
not moving ssam about plus you know I'm
always trying to push the brand so good
a lot of people watch that show the
kool-aid oh my god you got your entrance
down oh yeah oh that [ __ ] wins that
wins the [ __ ] Internet
excellent [ __ ] choice if they don't
do a kool-aid man on that show they're
[ __ ] leaving the low-hanging fruit
just like I got no business making a
show um you got any other questions you
like better [ __ ] wonderful but no no
no all the questions those were there
ten well there it is we did a show for
you folks let's see 9:45 we started like
7:30
yeah 737 42 hours to our show with
nobody here you know what we learned
today
[ __ ] audience we wish everyone was
here so much more fun when people are
laughing with or at us doesn't really
matter and hopefully we'll get back to
those [ __ ] heady days folks when we
can all stand much closer to each other
than me and Mark are right now but until
then what can we what can we do where
can we send them someone asked me on my
phone where did I'm wearing the shirt
like it says I assure you we're open
the chivor II that's where they're
selling a bunch of Kevin Smith Jay and
Silent Bob shirts yeah I don't have
anything to sell because we're very much
we're not [ __ ] on tour or anything
like that you could if you go to the
scum and villainy Facebook page yes we
are selling gift cards Oh which we get
the money from now yeah which helps us
you can use it here later and we're
giving 10% off so if you buy a hundred
dollar gift card or you buy a hundred
dollar gift card
we charging ninety here's a question I
saw somebody like I think it was a Jimmy
Fallon video where it said like
fundraiser or something on streaming
because we streamed on YouTube tonight
is there like a tip jar or a [ __ ]
thing
because maybe we can make it that like
if you're watching the show throw a few
bucks in for scum and villainy yeah we
could probably I have to look next time
tip jar like the [ __ ] like the cam
girls and the cam boys do just have to
work it man
we don't take a bow that would just each
take one yes and then watch the tip jar
go like doing ding ding ding ding other
negative tips how do they take money out
of an empty JC becomes like our pimp and
just work it work it harder both agree
sit down tips are low take them both out
like Coco and flat holy [ __ ] Grant
Gustin got naked he's got dark there it
is folks yes the next time we do this
maybe we'll put it up a donation jar so
it could go here to the good folks the
scum and villainy if you like the show
oh we can finally do that thing I've
always wanted to since I was a kid and
watch the little rascals every day
remember they put on a show and one time
they were like pay as you exit like they
didn't charge anybody until the show is
over and the show was a [ __ ] disaster
mark it was terrible but the everybody
they packed the barn and [ __ ] all the
little white kids
[Laughter]
so many poor awake and a lot of white
kids they packed the [ __ ] barn and
then the kids the little rascals put on
a terrible show and as they left you
know they were all like well we
shouldn't have [ __ ] let him pay as
the eggs that we should have got their
money up front no like I don't know
about our Spanky and they got all the
[ __ ] money cuz the kids were like
that show was so [ __ ] bad it was
worth the price of admission they
[ __ ] paid up so maybe that's what
we'll do a little rascals pay as you
exit cough that's nice if the show was
good enough and then the proceeds will
go right here to the bar if you like the
scum and villainy cantina you want to
see keep going and stuff there's a way
you can help a lot of folks being hit
hard of course by the coronavirus and
stuff some of my favorite food today was
what was it called eat out day or some
sectional take out day yeah the great
national take out day means eat out days
every day if you're doing right happens
yes ma'am but yes it's been of you know
if you it's it's tough time to ask
anybody to do anything for anybody else
does everybody gotta do stuff for their
selves and stuff like that but you know
like I eat in New York at PS kitchen all
the time and stuff and I got an email
from them about how like their staff is
just like laid off and stuff JC
mentioned before the staff here lay it
off what do they do what is it
unemployment
what are you doing from yeah everybody's
I mean nobody everybody works here's
hourly but I mean I'm not making any
money either like just everybody cut
everything just so we can is like we've
always loved this place and [ __ ] like
what a great [ __ ] idea and stuff like
that but now is the time like where it's
gonna get tough it's tough to run a
business and [ __ ] you can't run a
business and stuff but again when nobody
complaining nobody's like reopen the
[ __ ] world we understand why it's
closed and stuff but you know I
certainly am NOT gonna let this place go
cuz [ __ ] this is the only place where we
can do the show so yeah next time we do
this we'll put up [ __ ] tipped yard [ __ ]
like that yeah you could tell us what to
do for money
woo you're gonna go back to the Blue Man
Group after this yeah it's like you
and now Scheer all in the [ __ ] he just
won't take that mask off
you look like pirate Jenny from Watchmen
from The Watchmen show I'm talking about
you you're dr. Manhattan you got your
blue [ __ ] hands and oh oh no you were
I do have dr. Manhattan hands don't I
if only I could blue face up I just
re-watched the final two episodes of
that yeah the other day I mean I like
quarantine time means like a melee I do
a mixtape of movies where I'm like I'm
just gonna watch my two favorite scenes
from this one we jump over this one this
one so so I was I rewatched the whole
last two episodes that show is such a
beautiful gift it's so [ __ ] fantastic
so [ __ ] well done oh I'm not mad at
it for just calling quits no I'm not mad
at all I'm liking kidding me more [ __ ]
should be like that like it a beautiful
thing we made it and it was amazing
we're never gonna beat it goodbye and
out they [ __ ] just walk away yeah
there's been too much fun I always
thought that's how Twin Peaks should
have ended when Laura Palmer's murder
was solved and that was that but they
kept going and stuff so there it is man
buggin we'll be back next week hopefully
and doing this as a benefit for the scum
and villainy Cantina and for the benefit
of ourselves to be loved talking about
this [ __ ] can't do the show without my
man standing all the way over there give
it up for mr. mark barnard oh thank you
Kevin Smith and that ladies and
gentlemen is fat man beyond for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark Rinna tune
in next week same fad time same fat
channel SModcast calm or YouTube your
columns last Kevin Smith for the good of
all kreega night everybody